netflix's cowboy bebop is like a
live-action jam session riffing on the
much-loved original anime about a bunch
of bounty hunters in space yupikai movie
lovers i'm jan and in this video i'm
explaining the jazziest differences
between the new show and the animated
classic at 49 years of age john cho may
be over 20 years older than his
character spike spiegel was in the
original anime but what the actor lacks
in youth he more than makes up for with
acres of effortless cool as the show's
lead space cowboy cho exudes laid-back
charisma and rye wit breathing
entertaining life into spike's often
cynical and cavalier approach to the
world while also managing to tap into
his darkness and vulnerability
interestingly portraying vulnerability
was something spike's english language
voice actor in the anime steve blum said
he found especially difficult and that's
the benefit john cho sees of coming to
the role as a more mature actor as he
feels he's better now at showing
weakness and vulnerability and love so
is more able to do justice to the
emotional depth they've tried to give
spike as for creating spike's look cho
trained hard to become what he calls
functionally rather than show horse
athletic to get a good performance and
also developed a character walk for the
first time in his career by watching how
spike moves in the original series and
that hair is cho's own grown out rather
than a wig which he was keen to avoid so
it would feel and look more natural and
wouldn't pull on his scalp during the
show's many action scenes
equally superb is mustafa shakir as
former cop jet black fans of marvel's
luke cage will doubtless remember the
actor as bushmaster in season two of
that show in cowboy bebop shakir brings
his anime counterpart to pitch perfect
life with a scene it all before
gruffness mixed with heart and humor as
well as great on-screen chemistry with
cho this time around a young daughter's
included in jet's backstory adding a
personal layer to the professional hurt
he suffered in his past while that's not
really necessary to get us on board with
his character it does lead to a small
but emotionally devastating moment for
him as well as some amusing moments
along the way my favorite of which is
him watching his daughter's school
performance in the foreground totally
oblivious to spike fighting a slew of
baddies alone in the background
the third member of the b-bop's crew fey
valentine arrives on the scene a bit
earlier than in the anime and given
daniela pineda's fantastic turn as fae
it's absolutely for the best pineda's
take on the bold brash amnesiac brings a
sense of wicked fun to the show whenever
she's on screen whether she's bantering
with spike and jet or getting herself or
others into and out of crazy jams like
in the ridiculously good seventh episode
with the odd exception faye doesn't keep
abandoning the team as their animated
counterpart often did which improves the
chemistry she has with her fellow bounty
hunters in fact all three lead actors
work brilliantly together producing a
truly entertaining dynamic plus pineda
imbues faye's search for her missing
past with a quiet melancholy and this
will be interesting to see how her hunt
for answers pans out in season two as
for her appearance obviously she was
going to look different in the real
world and her updated outfit reflects
that while nodding to the original
if you've watched amazon's superhero
series the boys you'll likely recognize
actor alex hassell who played
translucent in that show and stars as
vicious in cowboy bebop how much you
enjoy his turn here depends on how
theatrical you like your villains
compared to the anime we see much more
of vicious in the live-action series
given he's the show's main antagonist
building up his character and expanding
his backstory makes sense as it makes
him feel much more obviously integral to
the story from the get-go but the
penultimate episode that lays out his
journey to becoming a syndicate capo and
his relationship with spike is one of
the less interesting ones as it feels
like we've either been told or intuited
enough already so it ends up seeming
like an over long interruption before
the big finale by the way if you're
wondering what happened to vicious pet
cormorant from the anime the new show's
creative team made an early decision to
give it the chop which is understandable
given the added vfx cost to create
something that's not exactly crucial
however they did include various easter
eggs to the bird on vicious costume
julia who is vicious wife and spike's
former flame also gets a lot more screen
time than she did in the original series
where she was more enigmatic but she
still mainly exists just to be part of a
love triangle and actress elena sateen
does what she can with a character who's
mostly there to appear fragile and
sultry fortunately there's a hint of
more interesting times ahead given where
the show leaves her character and i'm
intrigued to see where the creators take
things in season two by the way satine
gets to showcase her singing and
according to john cho also plays the
piano herself in the series performing a
new song that's important for julia
similar to the anime welsh corgi and
datadog ein turns up in the lives of the
bebop crew thanks to a run-in with a pet
napper named hakeem in the live-action
series two super cute canines harry and
charlie bring iron to absolutely
adorable life though according to the
show's two male leads they were pretty
heavy to carry around as well as the
real life pups john cho says he also
spent a lot of time acting opposite a
stuffed toy dog to get his eye alignment
right in scenes where ein was off screen
in terms of how the show's adapted
overall it gets off to a delightfully
playful wacky start with spike and jess
at a casino on the hunt for their latest
criminal cash cow the scene is a joy to
watch from spike's elevator entrance and
fancy fighting footwork including a
casino chip dropkick to jet's arrival
crash landing through the ceiling to the
duo's bickering best mates back and
forth rather than simply remaking the
original episodes or creating an
entirely different narrative with the
same core characters the live-action
series aims to retain the anime spirit
and takes a pick and mix approach to its
plots and characters in other words they
get everybody in the stuff together but
in a variety of ways for instance the
first episode takes a similar attack to
the anime pilot introducing asimov and
katarina and their attempted red-eye
drug deal but in a change it also
introduces fae how the creative team
re-jigs or remixes elements often works
but at times they don't quite pull it
off for example i was glad i already
knew the anime when i watched the
eco-terrorism episode with maria murdock
because the live-action take on that
felt a bit too rushed to fully take him
properly each episode gives the bebop
crew fresh criminals to bounty hunt like
in the anime however this version takes
more regular time from the start to
expand on the crew's histories so those
episodes feel less like standalone
stories and more clearly like part of a
bigger overarching narrative the series
is packed with easter eggs and hat tips
to the original from building names to
complete shots and composer yoko kano's
back with new music as well as old
favorites including her iconic opening
theme tune thank goodness because i
really love that
spoilers now for the season one ending
the appearance of hacking wiz kid
radical edward was teased a few times
this season i got a lead from radical
egg but ed only appears right at the
very end even though it's just a brief
glimpse we can see this version has the
signature look and the hyper child-like
energy and smiley eccentricity you'd
expect however fan reactions have been
mixed with some suggesting that ed's
anime oddness doesn't translate well to
live action we'll have to wait till
season two to see exactly how the
character plays out but i wonder whether
radical ed will hack into the bebop to
force jett to come and join her spike
and ein similar to how she hijacked the
ship in the anime
although anime ed's entertaining on
screen in a world of ever increasing
data hacks and breaches getting yourself
a trustworthy virtual private network is
a crucial part of keeping your online
life private and secure which is why at
flicks in the city we recommend nordvpn
who sponsored this video whether you're
using public wi-fi or at home you're at
risk from hackers who can break into
your connection and access any personal
data being transmitted a vpn protects
your privacy by encrypting your internet
connection and preventing your internet
service provider the government or
snoopers from knowing what websites
you're visiting and from reading your
private messages and it's also a
powerful tool that can help you bypass
geolocation blocks so that you can
access content not available to view or
censored in your country something we
especially like about nord is the super
fast download speeds on its 5000 plus
servers and how it uses next-gen vpn
technologies like wire guard and with
our exclusive cyber month offer you can
get a huge 73 percent of a two-year plan
plus one month free just visit
nordvpn.com flicks or tap the link in
the video description to access the
offer or use coupon code flicks when you
check out now what did you think of the
new cowboy bebop and who's your favorite
character in either version let me know
in the comments below and if you enjoyed
this then a thumbs up and a share hugely
appreciated next tap here to learn about
the biggest changes between june 2021
and 1984 or tap right for something else
you're sure to like thanks for watching
and see you next time yupikai movie
lovers
you